today's episode of what if discussed is
brought to you by
policy genius at what point will we
attain
type 2 status well remember now we're
talking about centuries to maybe a
thousand years into the future
this means building the first starships
so we're going to go far beyond the
solar system and reach out to the nearby
[Music]
stars
[Music]
so pete how you doing today i'm good how
are you doing
you seem surprised that i'm asking you
how you're doing it's just an odd way to
start
but i know you say it every week but it
seemed like you were putting me on the
spot for some reason
well i mean in this case i was actually
concerned i am concerned with how you're
doing but more
in the context of energy how are you
feeling energetically
uh well i mean here we're sitting in
august of 2020 and
uh just oh is this the tail end of the
pandemic really i don't know
i think like a lot of people who are
working from home not everybody's
working from home but i am
a lot of people are taxed they're uh
they're they've
expended a lot of their energy they're
low and i mean i think most people would
answer the question the same way most
people feel
they don't have enough energy they could
use more energy because at the end
we're all energy including our planet
okay now i see where you're going with
this you're talking about
and because of par probably the uh the
topic of today's show everything is
energy
everything is energy and in this case
how planets are sort of categorized
according to the kardashev scale which
is something we'll get into later
there are type 1 type 2 type 3
civilizations and it's according to how
much energy
they can harness from in this case type
2
that you can harness from the sun i we
have done a few
kardashev scale like videos on
what if um and i don't recall are we a
type
one well bad news we're not a type one
yet we're actually type
zero which is not something that yeah it
feels depressing but we have nowhere to
go but
up okay which is another way to look at
it it's kind
of like type 2 would be more like
solar power on steroids okay solar power
on steroids so it's like the sun
but we're getting all of our power from
the sun we're able to harness all that
power from the sun
and store it too yes and store it which
as you can imagine would allow us to do
a whole bunch of things
not things that i would necessarily
understand nor did i really understand
this prior to
probably hours ago but that's why we
have guests on the show because we want
people to be able to come on and explain
some of these complicated
topics like what if earth became a type
2 civilization
and in this case we're lucky enough to
have somebody who's
a bit of an expert on the subject and
who we've also had on the show before
yeah we have it's uh
professor michio kaku who's extremely
uh smart and well respected and and
followed by a lot of people
and really one of the people who are
most cited and quoted when you're
talking about today's what if
what if the earth became a type 2
civilization
[Music]
michio kaku is known as a futurist a
great communicator
and a popularizer of science he first
graduated
summa [ __ ] laude from harvard university
in 1968
and received his phd from berkeley in
1972.
kaku has expertise in several fields
such as hadronic physics
super symmetry super gravity super
string theory
and super quantum no not super quantum
physics just quantum physics
he's also quite the media maven with
multiple best-selling books to his name
including his most recent the future of
humanity
he also hosts two radio shows and
appears regularly in television series
exploring space
physics in the future he's currently the
city college of new york's
henry c matt professor of theoretical
physics
where he's been teaching for 35 years
professor kaku welcome back to what if
discussed
glad to be on the show and we're always
glad to have you
and for sure as peter and i talked about
off the top it's
it's a complicated subject this type one
type two civilizations if you don't know
the kardashev scale
uh and of course i think we did our best
to try to understand
and explain it but this is why you're
here because obviously
this is something that you're considered
one of the experts on this planet so
first of all
please clarify what is the kardashev
scale and what is a type 1 type 2 type 3
civilization
well we physicists are tired of talking
about flying saucers and little green
men
and speculating about life and space
i'm a physicist we use energy energy
to rank civilizations in outer space
a type one civilization is planetary
they consume all the energy that they
receive from the sun
for example they control the weather a
type two
is stellar they control all the energy
output of the mother sun
sort of like the federation of planets
in star trek
they've colonized a few of the
neighboring planets they bring star
systems but not much more
then there's type three type three is
galactic they roam the galactic space
lanes
they can harness the energy of a hundred
billion stars in the galaxy
sort of like uh star wars star wars
would be an example of a type
three galactic civilization now what are
we
do we play with the weather play with
volcanoes and play with earthquakes
do we play with the sun do we play with
black holes throughout the galaxy
no we are type zero
we don't even rate on this scale we get
our energy from
dead plants oil and coal
but we are about a hundred years away
from attaining type one status for
example the internet
what is the internet it is the first
type one telephone system
to be unleashed in this century
what language will this type 1
civilization speak
well already english and mandarin
chinese are the two greatest languages
on the
internet and what is the european union
what is nafta
what are all these trade blocs the
beginning of a primitive
type one planetary economy
now if you keep the scale up at what
point will we attain
type 2 status that is leave this solar
system and start to explore the nearby
stars
well you just take out a slide rule or a
calculator
you can calculate that in just a few
thousand years
we will be type 2 like captain kirk
now captain kirk lives in the 23rd
century
so that's about right a little early
but still well on the scale that nikolai
kardashiaf formulated in the 1960s
then you hit type 3
in about 100 000 years wow and why is
that
because that's the energy that you
attain the planck energy
the planck energy is the energy of
space-time
it's when space becomes unstable
wormholes develop black holes
gateway high-speed spatial gateways
through space
and time that's the planck energy the
planck energy is a quadrillion times
more powerful
than the large hadron collider outside
geneva switzerland
and why do i mention that because once
you obtain the planck energy
wormholes maybe even time travel is a
possibility
wow um let's bring it back down to earth
and uh
and uh talk about type two i i was
asking off the top whether a type 2
civilization
was simply like solar power on steroids
now i know you're not going to quote me
in your next book as a
genius insight but how close is
that idea to to what type 2
means well type 2 does not mean
simply getting sunlight from the sun it
means playing with the sun
itself for example a dyson sphere
would envelop the entire sun with a
sphere
to absorb 100 percent of the energy
output of a star that's a dyson sphere
and astronomers think that well we're
not sure
but we may have the signals from some
potential candidates
of being a type 2 civilization in outer
space
there's a storm called tabby star which
drops in
intensity by about 25
some people think that maybe a gigantic
jupiter-sized planet moves in front
of the star absorbing all this energy
and perhaps that is a dyson sphere in
outer space
wow and a type 2 civilization would be
like star trek
the federation of planets they've
colonized a small quadrant of the galaxy
would be a type 2 civilization
energy is something that we i don't know
it i don't
mean we don't talk about energy because
we talk about energy but
as important as energy is to our
day-to-day lives and our functions
be in on this planet survival but even
beyond you'd think
we'd have even more focus i think we
take it for granted obviously you just
walk into a room turn on a light switch
etc
but as you said earlier we we still are
at a pretty primitive level
of harnessing energy which is again
fossil fuels
how important is it that we let's say
fast forward our harnessing of solar
power
to not only get to type 2 civilization
one day but to expedite the evolution of
this species
well let's take a look at it
historically throughout most of human
history for 99
of human history we had about a quarter
of a horsepower
per person the strength of your left
hand
and right hand and that's it folks that
was the
energy output for most of human
civilization about a quarter of a
horsepower
then when we domesticated horses about
10 000 years ago
we went from a quarter of a horsepower
to one horsepower
and that began what is called
civilization
cities armies empires began to be formed
and then just 300 years ago we
discovered the steam engine
and as a consequence we went from one
horsepower
to maybe 10 horsepower in a buggy
in a locomotive now of course you have
access to
thousands of horsepower and in fact
we're going to use that energy to rock
it into
outer space so you see that the progress
of civilization
can be mapped by the progress in energy
harnessing that we've been able to
harness thousands of horsepowers for one
astronaut
well before it was only the strength of
your left hand and your right hand
now you mentioned energy sources of the
future solar is one
but there's another one i think that is
even more important
and that's fusion power now fusion power
is still a few decades away
but fusion power is the power of the
universe
wow it's what makes the sun shine it's
what makes the stars twinkle
and we're going to be able to i think in
a few decades harness that fusion power
on the planet earth to give us unlimited
amounts of
energy from sea water sea water is the
basic fuel
for fusion plants and we have one in
france
it's called the iter fusion reactor
in kardash france built by the european
union with the help from the united
states and russia
and japan and we hope to get fusion off
the ground in the coming decades
well just so we book you in it far
enough in advance
i'd just like you to put in your
calendar that when that happens we'd
like to have you back on the show
because ideally
you and i would still be alive peter
we'd still be doing what if discussed
but uh like right now i would say let's
just put a pin in that for now
let's say we jump in the time machine
and go right there the what if time
machine
peter start it up yes we haven't used it
in a while so let's say
all the theoreticals are behind us we
are now
at that point where we are a type 2
civilization
what are some of the kind of cool things
that people would be
sort of fascinated by that a type 2
civilization as
earth would be able to do whether it's
controlling the weather the atmosphere
you know blowing asteroids out of the
sky like what are some of the things
that we should be able to expect
as a type 2 civilization well remember
now we're talking about centuries to
maybe a thousand years into the future
well we'll have pretty much colonized
the entire solar system
out to pluto and maybe out to the nearby
stars
we're going to build the first starship
perhaps within 100
200 years nasa already has the 100 star
100 year starship program looking at
potential propulsion systems for a
starship
uh for example antimatter engines uh
fusion engines um even ramjet fusion
engines
these are all possible engines for
starships
now we're not talking warp drive to get
warp drive you'd have to be type three
but by the time you type uh one and
aspiring toward type two
this means building the first starships
so we're going to go far beyond the
solar system and reach out to the nearby
stars
there's even a program called the
breakthrough star shot program
uh stephen hawking my late colleague
was a member of that program and he
believed that yes
we should build the first starship not
in a few hundred years but in this
century
just in this century build the first
starship
well one of the great things about
having you is that
regardless of where we're at
individually or collectively
i'm always optimistic and excited after
i speak to michio kaku because
you see the future in such a way that is
uh especially in these times
uh encouraging and exciting and yeah
and wow it gives us a reason to sort of
you know look forward beyond our sort of
day-to-day problems and be excited about
it it's interesting because we talked
about
you know homo sapiens being around for
200 000 years
yes and professor kaku is saying you
know all you had for power was
you know for horsepower and now we're
100
years away probably yes and i mean 100
years away we couldn't fly
or sorry 100 you know a little over 100
years ago we couldn't fly so and then
you know 50 years later 60 years later
we're sending people to the moon so
incredible as
as you are always adept at doing you get
us sort of steered in the right
direction
we're gonna have uh professor kaku on
later if you want to listen to this full
in-depth interview
beyond our conversation that we just had
click on the link below because a
special treat
we are going to be breaking down
uh your most recent new york times
bestseller the future of humanity i
don't think it's overstating it to say
that this is one of those times where
you want to be
thinking about the future of humanity
but especially
the insights and the visionary
perspectives that you have
in the book give us a little idea of
what we're going to be hearing about
and what people can expect to find in
the book the future of humanity
well you know the the dinosaurs did not
have a space program they did nothing
they're not here today
there are no dinosaurs joining us for
this interview today
because they got wiped out they were
clueless they didn't know what hit them
well we do have a space program and it's
inevitable that we're going to have
crises
for example volcanic eruptions meteor
impacts
pandemics we know they're going to be
crises of the future
and we need an insurance policy an
insurance policy
to make sure that humanity survives no
matter
what catastrophes uh hit the planet
earth
and the main stumbling block preventing
that was
a four-letter dirty word cost
it cost ten thousand dollars to put a
pound of anything
into orbit around the planet earth
that's your weight in gold
think of your body made out of solid
gold that's what it costs just to put
you in orbit
around the planet earth well now prices
are dropping because elon musk and
others are perfecting the reusable
rocket
because of competition because of
private public
collaboration the price of space travel
is dropping
like a rock this means that in the
future mom and dad
may be able to go to outer space and i
would even predict that our grandkids
may have the option of honeymooning on
the moon
cool not the dark side of the moon
though because that's not a good way to
start a relationship a little more
private
um so again more with dr kaku uh about
everything future of humanity you don't
want to miss this
so click on the link below and you're
going to get a really in-depth
dive into a rabbit hole that's going to
cover so many topics about the short
medium and long-term future of humanity
on this planet
dr kaku talked about insurance policies
peter
it sounds like the perfect segue to talk
about our friends at policy genius well
done professor kaku is not necessarily
an insurance
uh salesman um but he's a genius he's
possibly not a policy definitely not a
policy genius well
policy genius is an insurance
marketplace and there comes a time in
life when it becomes evident that
people need some life insurance but uh
the world being a little topsy-turvy
right now it certainly is yeah pandemic
it's it's a deadly pandemic and you
might be thinking okay well
can you buy life insurance when there's
a deadly pandemic because is it inflated
will they cover me yeah
well the short answer is yes you can buy
life insurance during a pandemic and if
you have loved ones depending on your
income it's a really good idea uh best
place to go for the best rate
policy genius policy genius like i say
is an insurance marketplace
they're in contact with the life
insurance companies on their platform
every day
keeping track of keeping track of the
insurance market so that you don't have
to they've got the expertise to cover
you quickly
and at the best price they compare
quotes from the top life insurance
companies all in one place
just takes a few minutes to compare
quotes from the top insurers
and that saves you a lot of legwork and
it saves you a lot of money
yeah up to 1500 or more per year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policy so
if you're looking to buy life insurance
if you're not sure where to start
head on over to policygenius.com it'll
get you and your family protected and
hopefully give you one less thing to
worry about
so yes i guess we have a lot to look
forward to would be the glass half full
because
we're type zero as as professor kaku
talked about
were hundreds of years away from
probably being a type one and
thousands of years away from being a
type 2. this is like i mentioned is this
is
uh heartening for me as opposed to
disheartening for me
in that like i say the human
homo sapiens have been here for 200 000
years
and all the progress we've made is
basically to get to here
and he thinks in 100 years 200 years we
could be a type 1 civilization
my gosh like how incredible is that
progression
in 100 years compared to the last 200
000 years i'd love to see that on the
news more
right because it's so easy as he talked
about that we we get so focused on the
present and you know
if you're a zen buddhist you'd say well
that's where you want to be you want to
be in the moment
but we also get fixated on this
particular time
as though this is you know this is the
the future of the species is basically
the next 10 no it's hundreds of years
thousands of years regardless of even
what happens in the short term
we in the planet are going to be around
a long time in some form
and it seems crazy obviously as we sit
here today that
the energy that we use and harness is
still you know
as he said like you know plants and and
and
fossil fuels when you have decaying
dinosaurs decaying dinosaurs
and the focus on the sun isn't new but
hearing this
you think man if we really focused all
our attention on solar power and then
you know further harnessing that power
so we've got
this enormous yellow burning ball of
fuel that i can feel on my face when i
walk down the street
it's burning all day long and certainly
we
our earth rotates but why are we not
expending all our energy
expending all our energy into capturing
the energy from something that's free
something that's incredibly powerful and
something that's so close rather than
like
you know bugging around with all this
junk underneath the dirt we're the only
species in the in the world that
actually has the ability
to delay its own evolution
because we have we've known this for 50
60 years that obviously there's a way to
get
solar power uh you know make it
ubiquitous around the world and
essentially make energy
as close to free as possible but our
focus hasn't been there our focus has
been
in other ways and of course once you
have that linked to your economy
nobody's in a rush to sort of change the
status quo and that's kind of been the
case
i think though not only is the is the
will there by most people or many people
around the world i think it's starting
to see that the the the political
currency is there as well so i think
we're doing the show in 10 years it's a
different story because i think we're
going to be way further down the line
on way more solar and way less fossils
yes we're ten years closer to that you
know
30 years in which we're all going to die
yeah don't
stop burning fossil fuels and treating
the planet like
we don't have a great history as being
proactive
but we have a pretty good history as
being reactive are we the only
uh species that could end our own
evolution as well
i would think so outside of lemmings i
think lemons
can just run off cliffs but as a whole i
mean all over the world they can't
coordinate their
no i mean it's it's funny because we're
supposed to be the smartest species in
the world yet
we have that unique ability which is you
could argue
not smart exactly if you want more
with professor michio kaku like we said
there's the full audio podcast
uh click on the link below and you'll
get about 20 more minutes with us and uh
professor michio kaku
it's going to be really interesting
trust me talking about the future of
humanity which we're kind of doing here
but of course
at a kindergarten level so if you want
to hear somebody who really has
an incredibly visionary perspective on
an exciting and optimistic perspective
on the future of the species humanity
the planet etc you're going to want to
stick around for this because
again every time we talk to michio kaku
we we usually leave
you know kind of smiling you're smiling
and feeling a lot better about things
he's he's talking about things that
make you happy rather than it's not the
end of the world for him it's the
possibilities
of what we can do well said peter what
are the possibilities
of you coming back and watching another
what if discussed maybe next week
well why don't you because this one's
over thanks for joining us here on what
if disgust